what do you think of cardboard if you
think of it at all you probably think
about boxes and all the cool stuff that
comes inside but what the box could fly
that's the idea behind this it looks
like a like a pizza box that's been
shaped into a wing this is the apsara
it's a cardboard glider drone that can
carry about two pounds of cargo it was
developed by ever fly a division of San
Francisco robotics company other lab
here's our prototype it's a glider so it
just sort of floats through the air the
plane was developed through a DARPA
project to make a disposable drone that
could be used to precisely deliver
supplies in an emergency situation this
lets you do something that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to do if you had a
drone that was more expensive and you
wanted to say bring vaccines to where
they were needed you would not likely be
willing to let that drone go without
being willing to also go and retrieve it
so you could reuse it right now the
prototype planes are made of good
old-fashioned corrugated cardboard but
the final version will be more
biodegradable these ones are made out of
a mushroom based material and that means
that once they arrive where they're
needed they can decompose within a
matter of days the company thinks they
could be used by disaster relief and
humanitarian herbs anything from like
MSF nice awesome idea Red Cross type
organizations anybody who needs to get
medical supplies or medically sensitive
fluid places we'd love to work with
disaster relief organizations as well
well the drones can't carry as much as a
parachute they are far more precise
thanks to tiny controls and GPS you
program in coordinate and it'll glide
you where you want it to be within 50
feet because they will be made of a
cardboard like material the drones could
be shipped flat and put together where
they are needed it's a bit of origami
like thinking we start out with a flat
sheet and start to draw designs that we
then laser-cut this is both laser scored
and laser cut
so that when we get the flat sheets out
of the laser cutter we bend them and
fold them into the wing shape that you
see here ever fly tested its drone by
dropping one from an octocopter but the
idea would be to deploy hundreds or even
thousands from a cargo plane I really
enjoy getting to work on something that
can serve a function that is not
addressed by any other technology that
we need to really have so far
[Music]